you come to Cambodia and Vietnam going
down the Mekong River and you learn a
lot here the biggest realization I had
was the only exotic thing here is me
this place has been around for 2,000
years everything is perfectly normal but
this for me is the travel experience
questioning also your normal by going to
a place that has a different kind of
normal
my name is Christophe Neiman I'm an
illustrator and over the years I always
drew when I traveled one of the most
important things for me when I do these
trips is not to have any preconceived
notions you come there and of course I
feel the creative pressure to create a
story in time where the good images but
you have to live a little bit and you
have to allow for something to happen
and I go back and forth between your
mind and the place when I make a drawing
what I do is utterly subjective I look
at a landscape that consists of a
million different elements and I've
picked some out and make the bigger sum
through conscious decisions some through
just unconscious over there's this tree
I happen to have red ink so now the tree
is is is is red you filter the world
through the limitations of ink on paper
another aspect that's very important for
me when I create an image is a certain
kind of contrast and drawing is great
because you can amplify contrasts we go
to Angkor Wat in the morning for sunrise
which is an incredible moment but even
though it's an incredible moment I've
seen pictures of that before so you
paired it against the photos that you've
seen
real life has a lot of people with
cellphones scrambling for the right
position to get the right moment of the
Sun reflecting in the in the water lily
pond I think you can take this stock
photo postcard moment that you have
stored somewhere and check that against
the reality my gold for a reader to look
at that and say yeah that's that's my
travel experience it's not this perfect
4k everything's amazing every detail is
photoshopped out but it's like the
moment where something is a little off I
think it becomes interesting where I see
what I do is really being like a
scientific amateur and almost you know
kind of turning the lens on myself and
how I experience this amazing world I
almost feel like I'm the reader who then
gets to stand in the middle of the story
and we just see what happens
[Music]